I am imprisoned for three years please
do not worry for me my father is also in
prison he is also in good health I wish
all the family members to be healthy
jihad Jose yeah good news the same post
about the photo gallery connemara Holly
Nevada Duke 12800 M le vamos a la playa
heart-machine - con Maga yeah - our
overall affair mother
[Music]
in February 2018
I shall cotton got a letter she wasn't
expecting it was a message from a son
jarred written inside gel and Myanmar's
Rakhine State she also received a short
note from an elderly husband sitting
Mandela Hassan and the gamma sea water
cannon level year dual jaw then away it
was the first time I had heard from a 25
year old son and husband since they were
arrested by a Myanmar army suite in
August 2017 the wave of violence had
forced more than 700,000 Ranjha
including 50 year-old
I shan't her remaining nine children to
flee across the border to neighboring
Bangladesh another Sakamoto sergei
volkov angry ecology meager ideals sol
doesn't agree maybe the Jada's in the
normal value will be rising so high just
for that movie Oliver an unfamiliar
familiar did you get that say he does it
bother you does it
yeah no no Dina man you know you hear a
lot about Terra Dina so did not she
Sarah I kill mother even the horizon
another psycho manual in Hawaii after
that I had no news from her husband and
son until the letter arrived in Santa
Ala Moana she does another for a better
for sadness any like comedy
I saw it on an elephant how was it irani
diggity like a with zero plan iran-iraq
war abandoning forever right now see so
he does it how was it or anything it is
Antalya
sorry I was in the other side I'm not
God if I have a failure
so Ashley Melinda Lake Erie Tadasana I
see like I was your mother saying we
were lawfully on my DVD and I tell Santa
a lot during the weeks of violence
soldiers murdered raped and arrested
thousands of Ranger which the United
Nations said military leaders must face
genocide charges for Myanmar denies the
allegations with entire villages raised
red cross workers have said many stuck
in Myanmar are desperate to know if
their families made it to the safety of
the camps in Bangladesh and like Asia
thousands unable to go back a keen to
know if their loved ones survived that's
not it buddy you know I got my g2
Gosselin is horrible you know what it is
all over the world well you obviously
have three degrees in viajar are aware
about what we gotta say na koni
economist I still AM
gara gara for allegedly it's funny no
Haryana karate very on the karate movie
does it feel of America every year here
- Micaela Ramazzotti haha Ordaz Eric
reactor - almaty my mother she
[Music]
we are to be sick on Mohammad Ahsan your
point and I collided awesome boo that's
yeah that's who I knew Santi and I gonna
be shaky and I are what idiot you're
gonna I do one night you know go to do a
Lucan Madonna
there's a master how can ya did what was
in the high high low high Nirvana hiding
in the eyes of another point Jenny AHA
and I are like a lot of commercials on
my Avandia these scraps of paper carried
across borders offer a rare source of
hope for families between August 2017
and October 2018 the International
Committee of the Red Cross collected
more than 2,400 messages and tracing
requests from people on both sides of
the Myanmar Bangladesh border Red Cross
workers have made seven prison visits in
Rakhine to monitor treatment and
conditions of those detained yet all
communication in and out of jails are
censored by Myanmar and that means
letters are limited to family news the
notes written down by red cross workers
in English and Burmese in Dada Sahara
Nigeria - yah yah yah ha-ah - muffled
yeah Tina Tina Chavez oh yes in Terre
Haute our function baron de la corte
vendetta are in the commode are adenine
valuing a very nice hotel hotel cinta
bhagavata de la fórmula una escena en la
Santeria Ottawa Holland area
you